let the final battle begin
we won't surrender
we make our last stand
star wars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
please pass time only now the thousand
generations live in you now but this is
your side
on December 20th
the saga
we'll end
[Applause]
let the final battle
again
starwars the rise of skywalker get
tickets now
right now
they fly now
confronting fear
the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
it's okay that we're here it's okay that
you're here it's good to see you that to
us
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
this will be the final word
in the story of Skywalker
[Music]
starwars the rise of skywalker get
tickets now confronting fear it's the
destiny of a Jedi your destiny
[Music]
if this mission fails it was all for
nothing
[Music]
we're not alone good people will fight
if we lead them
[Music]
yah-tchi yes it's in star wars arise of
Skywalker tickets available now oh we've
done all this time we doing there are
three bill taking one last look sir at
my friend
[Music]
confronting fear
is the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
we're all in this
command and Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker tickets available now
[Music]
confronting fear
is the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Applause]
tickets available now
you